hey guys it's dense the founder thing
here and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book in the video game guru and is
our review of boardwalk empire season 4
episode 10 white horse pike yes I mean
the thing about boardwalk empire is
because they do a lot of setup it's hard
for me to watch because I love the show
yeah having the show one hour at a time
is tough because they they set up all
these things especially now because they
we kind of know where everything's
headed now yeah cuz you know obviously
in the beginning of this season it's
always like what's going on cuz you know
there's like who's this guy what's he
doing here why and then as slowly as the
season progresses and start to see okay
this this is where they're going with
this storm line and this character and
all this stuff and we're kind of
reaching that point now because there's
only two episodes left yeah okay we now
know what's going the only person I
don't know is is Ron Leveson's character
with Jillian I don't know I always
exactly what someone had commented in
our YouTube sections about maybe he's
like working with Tolliver or something
like that I don't know undercover agent
yeah I don't know if that's true enough
but other than him we we know what's
going on right and so you know obviously
the what I like about the season is it
revolves the season revolves a lot
around chalky yeah we're getting a lotta
yeah I always want him to get more
screen time understand more of his side
of the story and now we're getting that
now which is great we're getting the you
know the african-american community what
they're going through and their their
gang their gang world is and what their
life is I mean skipping ahead but to the
end we can see a conversation with his
daughter we're getting more discovered
with his kids and his family it's been
this one really good the season yeah and
you know that this episode ends with him
almost getting killed again again he's
had a rough season but this time I think
with the kite where the problem is is he
thinks that it's not yeah he's going
right because Nucky is the one who
called the mayor to get the two sheriff
to come escort him right and so right
now Chalky's on the run and he thinks
it's it's Nucky so how is Nucky going to
because this kind of this whole season
Nucky
kind of been on the sidelines with
Jackie he's he's told truck look this is
your problem you deal with it with dr.
Narcisse I'm staying out of it I don't
want a fight Bobo in this episode he
kind of said okay look I don't want a
war I want a warm but if it comes down
to it and I have your back because you
had my back last last whatever right
yeah in in the last season yeah so now
we know where chalky aired night right
we're Nucky stands he stands with chalky
when he tried to get him out of there
even though he made that deal with Joe
Masseria wrong and dr. Narcisse he's
still loyal to chalky but now chalky
doesn't know that yeah I don't think I
mean Narcisse needs to go I mean he's in
the way of everything he's messed
everything up I don't really think
knocky knocky even really cares that
much about Missouri Masri has power
though he is a boss but I mean I think
if he wipes you know in our seats out he
could make a deal with ma zouri on his
own you know I liked there's so much
stuff going on right now it's crazy
something us up with Meyer and Luciano
and then well you said you weren't too
sure about you know Ron Livingston's
character with Julian but I'm really
curious about where where's Eli like
where is he now is he like we're doing
our talk about his he did he make a deal
like with the Fed like for real or does
Nucky know about the deal I mean how far
did he go when he saw his son at the end
is he how is he maybe is he gonna tell
Nucky about it maybe resin told him yet
now he's gonna tell what I want his son
to go to jail hit they'll get busted in
his son would I mean less he gets his
son out I mean what is yeah I don't know
I wonder where he lies mind is right now
yeah cuz then he also helped you know do
the bust right was the heroine I saw him
and I was like yeah but i guess it was
part of the whole like okay that taller
guy is still so the crew right is still
one of the paid rise but I I don't know
where that we're that's going in terms
of how the outcomes gonna be but we do
know that a lie could you know go either
way yeah I mean and then we're miss
epistle really pulled back and we didn't
see everybody we saw a lot of people we
got some awesome scenes with mr. you
know mr. Harrow half face yeah it was
cool to see him and chalky kinda had
that my two favorite care yeah that was
cool let me help him out
like shook hands I can't remember
exactly maybe some of the comments that
you can pointed out worth their
relationship is in previous seasons I
don't know what happened like they said
like look I know this man I respect
everybody needs to make some money so
that was cool and then you know I guess
if we swing back I was like seeing going
to New York and seeing you know a
roasting with Margaret yeah with
Margaret that was great too yeah it's
weird different yeah cuz she's she wants
to get out of where she's living because
it's ghetto boy at the same time she
wants to earn her I hate this yeah
you're basically still doing crime it's
like you're not but I mean I get what
she's saying she it's a crime deal but
she earned this dealer deal it's not
Nucky's deal yeah I wonder how that's
gonna factor into the larger picture but
I'm back more I don't know because she
was gone for most of the season then
they brought her back but in small doses
and we don't know how that's gonna play
out and how Rothstein is even gonna play
out in this whole thing with Mozilla and
like it if Nucky's going to war is he
going he's going to war with maza reah
dr. Narcisse how 20 al capone how does
al capone factor into this cuz we see
that that it's possibly at the you know
when he gets shot at it could be Torrio
it could be Torrio I think that's all
cuz at the end he's like it's good thing
that Tory 11 like he's like there's like
whew good thing Toria wasn't here yeah
he see Michael chances like he wasn't
being sarcastic no he was serious this
year's I think he takes a little time to
get in there like he's probably gonna be
like hmm maybe Torrio hired these guys
yeah who knows I mean with O'Banion's
guys maybe but at the same time after
he's dead who knows if those guys
started working for grown or worked
somewhere else or split up and probably
the worst assassination attempt and TV
that I've seen in a while you don't call
somebody before you kill I would say I
just want to say goodbye that hesitate
and then Van Alden he showed his loyalty
but you know he hesitated he hesitated
but i really like wait i could get
killed too so i might as yeah
he was like looking at the window but he
was thinking like we should i save it or
not yeah I don't know but I think he
knows that he's put all his eggs in this
Al Capone basket and he needs Al Capone
to to prosper for him to prop the first
house give a garden ready you know it
did I i'm gonna guess it's Torrio just
because torial feels like oh this guys
getting too big britches he thinks he's
all you know he's running the show but
I'm gonna show him I'm gonna take him
out towards been pushed over a lot
lately but it makes you wanted to go
back to that whole you know time when he
got you know put sent to jail and
members that the the the the brewery
brabantia guys with the band's guys also
the cops come in the perfect time like
you wonder what's up with toria what he
sings Torrio last season got back from
Italy he was saying about Italy and how
great it was like he was out of the game
and that was like he's trying to get
back in but no one's taking cherry right
yeah I mean it was like he's I don't
think he even really wants to it's just
more pride like oh I'm the big boss I
don't like this guy trying to step up
and right then you know and we know that
Al Capone's gonna become a bit busy
right we've actually yeah so and yeah
and so I don't know these last two
episodes I'm excited for this we agree
from ala yeah yeah I mean last season
the last two episodes were you know kind
of like almost like a one right giant
movie and I feel like this is what's
gonna happen yes gonna be big I mean the
previous aw next week on there's some
some guy Chalky's going to see you know
some old dude these want to see in the
woods I got expelled who's this guy I
mean as always I just know what's gonna
happen I mean I still don't know about
you know Jillian like I said Ron
Livingston's character there's still a
lot of things to tie up I mean there's a
lot of loose ends but you know they do
it every year it's always a great great
last couple episodes yeah and uh how was
fine the dialogue to be so spot-on like
a lot of things that are said they had
like subtle meanie yeah a lot of subtle
humor in it and just like oh my god like
what's gonna happen next and so I don't
know I'm excited for it I think it's
gonna be good alright guys so you can
post your comments below on the website
think hero calm or on our YouTube
channel think hero pro make sure you
subscribe to that those gonna come child
us on Twitter for
myself all of us here at think hero
we're at think hero personally i'm at
griffin de and we have a Facebook page
that's a facebook.com slash think your
fans and make sure you like our page and
you tweet out our videos from the word
on Facebook and all that stuff